لطالما كان والدي شخصًا
مهووسًا بالطبيعة ، لذا فهو يحب
كل شيء بدءًا من صيد الأسماك والتخييم ،
وكل شيء بينهما
وما هو رائع حقًا هو أن هذا
يعكس شخصيته لأنه في مكان عمله
لديه أربعة أشياء سمكية
وهذا سيكون فظًا ولكن إذا
أي شيء صادق ، أنا أكرههم ، أنا أكره
كل حوض أسماك يمتلكه ،
ليس لأنني لا معجب بجمال
الطبيعة ولكنه يقضي الكثير من الوقت
والجهد في جعل أحواض الأسماك هذه
مثالية وأنا أجدها مملة بغض
النظر عن هذا.  الأيام التي تكون فيها حالتي
الذهنية تمامًا عندما أقول إنها
مزرية وأحيانًا عندما يكون مسافرًا
ويجب أن أذهب لإطعام هذه الأسماك ،
أذهب إلى مكتبه وأعتقد أنني أتخيل
الموقف الذي قد أكون مهووسًا به في
العثور عليك أو القدوم  في الخارج ولكن
لأكون صادقًا ، أتخيل نفسي كصيد أسماك حوض السمك الخاص به ، في
الأساس ، ما أفكر فيه هو شخص
من حوض السمك هذا يشرح لي
بيئة غير معروفة بالنسبة لي
بيئة من الهواء وليس
سقي مساحة غير مألوفة وأعتقد ما
إذا كنت سأقبل أفكارهم حول
هذه البيئة المجهولة غير المألوفة بالنسبة
لي ولم يكن لدي أبدًا إجابة
عما إذا كنت سأقبل
هذه البيئة أم لا حتى محادثة غريبة جدًا
أجريتها مع جدتي
لذلك قبل هذه المحادثة ،
كانت هناك مسابقة
للياقة البدنية واعتمدت مسابقة اللياقة البدنية هذه علي
تدريب CrossFit وجزء من
CrossFit هو رفع الأثقال ، لذلك خلال
المنافسة تم إطلاق فيديو سبع ثوانٍ
لي كنت مجنونة تمامًا كنت
أصرخ والفيديو نفسه أثناء
طرحت في المحادثة أسئلة
مثل ما يجب أن يقوله الناس عني
وماذا لديهم ليقولوه
حول حقيقة أنني كنت
أشارك في رياضة الوزن
وكنت غاضبًا حقًا لقد كنت غاضبًا حقًا لأنها
كانت قلقة للغاية  حول ما يجب أن
يقولوه عني على عكس ما يجب
أن أقوله عن نفسي وعن أدائي الخاص
، قالت شيئين لن
أفعلهما أبدًا  orget في نهاية المحادثة
نظرت إلي وقالت معك
ارتفاع الضحك نعم نعم نعم
الضحك أخلاقيات شهر العسل وتوقفت
ولكن المحادثة استمرت
والشيء الثاني الذي قالته هو أن
ما تفعله بهذه الطريقة مفرط
الشيء هو أنني لم أكن غاضبًا حقًا
مما قالته ، لكنني سمعت
هذه الأفكار قبل أن أسمع أن
ممارسة الرياضات ذات الوزن الزائد
ستجعلني أطلق لحية
وشاربًا وسيستدير  أنا في
شيء لست كذلك وأدركت أن
كل هذه الأشياء والأفكار كانت
موجودة أيضًا في حوض السمك هذا الذي
ولدت فيه ، لذلك عندما عدت إلى المنزل فكرت في
ما قلته فكرت في
هاتين العبارتين اللتين استمرتا في الرنين
رأسي ، لذا فإن العبارة الأولى
عنها حول تغيير
هرموناتي وما لم أفكر فيه وبحثت
عنها وأدركت أنه نظرًا لمستويات معينة من
الهرمونات وما إلى ذلك ومجموعة
من الأشياء العلمية ، فلن
يحولني إلى  الرجل ولكن الاعتبار  أقل من
ذلك قالت إنني كنت أذهب إلى
أقصى الحدود
وتصورت نفسي كأنني
ورقة بيضاء ورقة بيضاء حيث
خلقني ذلك الله
وبغض النظر عن عدد المرات التي تريد
طيها وفتح هذه القطعة من الورق و
إلى كل
أشكال الأوريغامي المختلفة والمثيرة للاهتمام التي لن تنكر
حقيقة أنه في نهاية اليوم ،
لا تزال هذه الورقة هي قطعة الورق التي
صنعها الله ، وتضيف أنني أتخيل نفسي
وأنني إذا كنت أرغب في ممارسة رياضة الأثقال أو
الكروس فيت أو إذا كنت  لا أريد أن
ألتقط رقصة الباليه التي لن تنكر حقيقة
أنه في نهاية اليوم
ما زلت المرأة التي أنا عليها وفكرت
في جدتي وفكرت في
سبب قولها لي هذه الأشياء
وأدركت أنني لا أستطيع أن ألومها حقًا ،
لا يمكنني أن ألومها حقًا لأنها
ولدت في حوض أسماك حيث نشأت
على تصديق أن الادعاء بأن الوزن
الرياضي سيكون السبب في
عدم الزواج على الأرجح  هو
سبب عدم حصولها على الإطلاق
بدأت أنا والأطفال في التفكير في
مدى اندماج هذه الأفكار بعمق
في مجتمعنا ، لذا فكرت في
اللغة في
كلمتين هما
جملتان فكرت فيهما حول العبارة الموجودة
أسفل دروجون وفكرت
في الكلمة التي تدرس  خذ الكلمة
أو العبارة الموجودة
أسفل trogir ، فهي تقارن
قوة المرأة وليس قوتها الجسدية
وقوتها العاطفية بقوة وقدرات الرجل
كما لو أن قوتها
وقدراتها وحدها ليست كافية ، ثم
هناك هذه الكلمات الثانية  أن الأشخاص
المحيطين بهذا ليس نوعًا من
الكلمات التحفيزية ويتم ترجمتها بشكل أساسي
إلى لغة أحادية وماذا
يتعلق بالمال ولكننا نحاول
تحفيز الفتيان والفتيات الصغار على أن
يصبحوا وحتى كلمة
rogen عندها  من الأصول اللغوية
أدركت أن الكلمة نفسها
تأتي من كلمة "المزيد"
ظروف الصحراء والنساء
هن اللواتي يتم وضعهن على
الإبل ولا يخطئن في فهمي ،
ربما يتم هذا بدافع
الاحترام وبغض النظر عن نوايا
الموقف والأشخاص الموجودين في
الموقف نفسه ولكن هذه
التوقعات و  القيود التي
فرضناها على الأجيال الشابة إلى
حد حيث يقيس الأولاد الصغار
تقديرهم لذاتهم من خلال محيط
العضلة ذات الرأسين ، بينما
تقيس الفتيات الصغيرات كرامتهن عن طريق SIA الغبي
ثم رأيت أنني فكرت في حدث
فكرت فيه في فصل الصالة الرياضية  كان فصل الصالة الرياضية في
الخارج ممتعًا لأنه
لم يكن هناك تمرين ضغط واحد ولكن تمرين
دفع كانا عبارة عن تمرينات لفتاة ،
ثم لم يكن هناك تمرينات ضغط للأولاد ولكن
تمرينات دفع حقيقية ،
ما أعتقد أنني كنت أتخيله على
أنه  يا أمي ، تخيلت
نفسي كأم مع
طفل صغير وفتاة صغيرة ترفض القيام
بتمرينات الضغط الحقيقية هذه على الرغم من قدراتها الجسدية
بركبتيها والركض فوق الأرض لمجرد
إنها لا تريد أن يسخر منها أصدقاؤها ،
فهي لا تريد أن
تُسمى رجلاً
لأنها ليست كذلك
، ثم تخيلت نفسي
كأم لهذا الصبي الصغير الذي لا
يستطيع في الأساس القيام بهذه الدفعة الحقيقية.  - مرات ،
لكن مرة أخرى يرفض القيام بتمارين الضغط هذه الفتاة
لمجرد أنه من بين
أصدقائه لا يريد أن يكون
رجلاً أقل من أن والده
ليس متأكدًا مما إذا كان أي منكم على
دراية برفع الأثقال المصرية
فريق أم لا ،
لكن بالنسبة لأولئك منكم الذين
سمعوا عنهم أو عنهم ، ستعرفون
أننا لم نقم بذلك ، وأنا شخصياً
مذنب بهذا حسنًا ، فنحن نرفض النظر إليهم
كنساء وهو أمر مضحك لأنهم يستطيعون ذلك.
أن يكونوا أمهات ، يمكن أن يكونوا بنات أخوات
وزوجات ، لكننا ما زلنا نعتقد
وأعتقد شخصيًا أن لدي
السلطة لأسميهم
شيئًا ليسوا شيئًا لم
يخلقهم الله وما حدث في
ذلك وأخيراً أعود  لمكتب والدي
وأعتقد وأنا المرجع  استخدم أنا أرفض أن يضعني أي شخص
في هذه الجدران الزجاجية الأربعة ويطلب
مني البقاء هناك
، وأرفض أن يخبرني أي شخص بأنه متطرف
أو جذري لمجرد أنني أريد
استكشاف الحدود التي تتجاوزها ، لذا
أرجو أن أعرف أن هناك
إمكانات CF  هناك ، لذلك اسمحوا لي أن أستكشفها بحرية
بشكل مشابه لكيفية
رغبة أي شخص في استكشاف أي شيء
آخر وحتى الزر أقر بحقيقة
أنه في بعض الحالات توجد
بيئات أخرى غير بيئتك
تمامًا مثل تلك التي أحتاجها للتحدث مع والدتي